um Okay so
do you guys think the woman is doing
the world of favor by having kids
is that in general yeah in general it
depends on the circumstances if she's
in a good relationship with someone then
then yeah it would be a good thing to
okay if she's single and just
yeah
most of the amazing world leaders we
have today were by women so yeah I would
think so but yeah in general yes because
women don't have kids then because we
often say that women are special because
we have children we do not say I would
say maybe they're more during doing like
a duty of nature or what they're meant
to do than than a favor do you think
it's a duty it's planned by Nature we're
doing what we put on this Earth to do
kind of well I know it doesn't sound the
best but don't I don't see it as a favor
it sounds like too much like a favor
it's like I'm I'm like created to do
that right so if the thing that makes
women special is having kids why do so
many women focus on their careers and
not becoming mothers are you talking
about the Modern Woman the mother woman
is not it's not a traditional woman so I
would think your question the first
question is truly take more to a
traditional woman so the modern woman
doesn't want to think traditionally but
they want traditional men it's funny
isn't it like yeah they're modern but
they want traditional men
they're very focused on what what did
you say with the career if they're more
focused on their Canadian if the thing
that yeah the thing that makes women
special is having kids because we'll say
things we're like the givers of life
right like why do we like they'll say we
won't run the world why like yeah yeah
that's that's calm you'd agree that's
like common in the culture yeah right
yeah yeah
um so why do so many women focus on
their careers instead of becoming
mothers this is the thing I think
feminism can brainwash you and it
brainwashed me a bit at some point where
you just sit down and think wait this
doesn't add up you just pick and choose
and that's very true what you say they
say we're special because we make
children but then yeah they push Focus
Korean independent boss lady
um just delusion of feminism yeah I
agree I agree with that
I think now also you can have kids later
on in life as well so females I didn't
realize that oh I can and like there's
more opportunities for women to go and
work it's easier life there's probably
more single women like later on so we're
gonna go and yeah but I don't think we
really can in general like we're fatter
than ever
and even even in the UK they'll call
America fat because yeah yeah
we are we are but the stats are not much
better here I looked it up one show I'm
like what are they bragging about
like I mean they're beating us but not
by much
that's like saying oh I got 45th Place
well yeah we're second in the world
right USA the first I don't I don't I
don't know where it is I just remember
looking it up and like thinking that you
guys were fatter than you really really
give yourself credit
but but so so I'd imagine if we're less
healthy right we probably don't have as
much opportunity to get have children
and it's it costs the average person
twenty thousand dollars to do in vitro
or any of that stuff so the most women
aren't going to be able to do that yeah
who's got time and there's no guarantee
that'll even work yeah who's got 20K
lying around to play with
anyone in here
no no
I'm not laying but
so it's like it's almost like they
brainwash you with that too would you
agree or disagree
yes but I think also it's like women go
off to University and after University
they're not telling you go and have a
family they're telling you go and work
you spent four years and wrapped up all
this debt you're gonna go work right so
they're not thinking like oh let me go
find a husband now because maybe most
men maybe at that age don't want to
settle down and have kids so they're
like well what am I gonna do was that
what you were was that where you like
maybe followed as well like try to go
uni what they said and focus on Career
no well I was like go to UNI and leave
this country that's right I'm like as
soon as you that's what I did as soon as
I finished bye yeah why
why it's cool yeah so many reasons like
now I'm like oh my gosh I love this
country what about that no it's cold it
rains all the time the cost of living is
high like it's people are just not not
then I feel felt like they're just not
nice like no one's friendly if if you
think it's not nice here come to Eastern
Europe
that is true
I remember
Latvia yeah so um I'm an athlete so we
raced in Latvia and it was in the indoor
track and I remember all I was doing was
walking from one part of the stadium to
the other and one of my guys was racing
and I remember I was walking and then I
saw this guy look at me and he looked at
me grabbed his girlfriend oh instead and
I'm just like I don't want your game and
he stared at me all the way to the
outside of the stadium
like they stare at you yeah a lot and I
was like I don't know
yeah I'm not gonna lie your Rarity I I
grew up in Lithuania first time I seen a
black person I was 18 and I was taking a
video from far
it's real like the first person
I recently went to Lithuania uh went to
Ebola and I was at another girl I was
chilling we were having a drink and some
guy walked over to you ate disgrace you
know to the woman probably she's between
him so obviously maybe you know I mean
but it was funny like you know it's a
bit intoxicated but it was that recently
did you say yeah recently like wow like
last month July yeah yeah yeah do they
have internet
listen no one knows this our internet is
like I think number one in the world the
fastest light speed so
as a Polish girl and she said that when
she lived in Poland the the image that
black people have in Poland was so bad
that when she came to England she was
surprised she was so nice she was like
oh my gosh she married a Jamaican man
had kids it's like in the Poland you are
not seen the same way no but women love
you the the Lithuanian Latvian women
love black people well it's just men
yeah yeah but the white women they they
like you what is it don't worry then uh
Poland recently during the Ukraine
Russian war the Africans away crossing
the border was getting sent back to
where the bombs were falling so they
were you know saving all the ukrainians
coming through to Poland but the African
the blacks were being pushed by so yeah
my mum went Poland with her polish
friend she said she loved it everybody
people were really nice
her friend's son was obsessive Bob
Marley my mom's got lost and he was like
he was very very what's the word
mesmerized yeah they change now they
changed yeah yeah but the students in
Lithuania are saying when they called to
get like an apartment they don't get
away from oh um I'm from Nigeria okay no
no really it doesn't matter
you literally have to have a little
girlfriend to even get a reference
but a lot of people are still really
nice like 90 you get nice experience
yeah it's opening up a bit but still
stuff out there so so I have another
question
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible